hey 42 here we've all battled traffic as
we sludge our way through a concrete Sea
on the way to work this my friend is the
disheartening reality of urban sprawl
the unbridled expansion of cities has
Unleashed a slew of nasty consequences
for people and the planet alike in fact
the UN predicts 68 of us will reside in
cities by 2050. so is it about time we
reviewed how we build those cities as
concrete jungles invade pristine
wildernesses precious ecosystems are
demolished resulting in dwindling
biodiversity and a demise of countless
species according to the World Wildlife
Fund habitat loss is the primary Peril
for 85 percent of all threatened species
also cities demand ever more water
energy and raw materials to grow which
is often correlated with higher air
water and soil pollution today Urban Air
Pollution is responsible for around 240
000 premature deaths in the EU every
year although it's interesting to note
that these figures have been falling
over the past decade as many European
cities seek to reduce their emissions
urban sprawl also gives us the joy of
lenphea commutes we forever find
ourselves traveling greater distances to
work school and elsewhere this only
fuels traffic congestion and air
pollution tarnishing our overall quality
of life the average American wastes 54
hours per year stuck in traffic
urban sprawl also threatens the little
green space that is left within most
cities Oasis like parks and Gardens
bestow Bountiful benefits upon city Folk
from mental health boosts to cleaner air
and opportunities for exercise as cities
bloat these Precious Places are often
gobbled up by new developments
after World War One skyscrapers were
hailed as the remedy to urban sprawl
they were rapidly built far and wide
especially in America
however these towering Giants aren't
without their faults they're pricey to
maintain and skyscrapers consume up to
70 more energy per square meter than
low-rise buildings skyscrapers are
arguably unsightly biermaster trade
Beauty for structural integrity and
maximal floor space
they also cast Long Shadows darkening
City spaces and they create wind tunnel
effects making adjacent streets
unappealing for pedestrians given these
pitfalls those pencil Fanatics we call
Architects have begun exploring
alternative Solutions and some have
sought inspiration from the very depths
of the Earth itself enter the Earth
scraper
Earth scrapers turn the concept of
skyscrapers on its head literally
burrowing deep into the grounds they
create layers of subterranean spaces for
humans to do whatever weird things
humans do would you like to improve your
writing unlock your creativity and
communicate more effectively introducing
grammarly go this powerful new tool
provides personalized generative AI
communication assistance helping to
accelerate your productivity and
creativity with grammarly go you can
personalize your voice and style of
communication just click set voice to
customize your tone and determine how
you want to sound this makes it so easy
to fine-tune your writing in your very
own style have you been stuck in a
creative Rock recently well grammarly go
has you covered simply impose a prompt
and watch as innovative ideas come
pouring in I absolutely love this
feature it's like having my own expert
brainstorming assistant right by my side
24 7. grammarly go can instantly rewrite
your text to reflect your personal style
and adapt to any situation no matter
what you find yourself doing whether you
need to make your writing sound more
exciting professional or concise
grammarly go is here to help I recently
used grammarly ghost who helped me draft
an email to my animator about how we
could add better visuals to one of our
recent videos and it did such an
incredible job I was hugely impressed
you'll be amazed at what you can do with
grammarly go so sign up at grammarly.com
42 underscore and get 20 off grammarly
premium today discover the power of
grammarly go and elevate your writing to
new heights big thank you to grammarly
for sponsoring this video now it's
probably dawned on you by now that Earth
scrapers aren't some fresh out of the
21st century oven concept it's merely a
snazzy term for a very ancient idea
the Cappadocia region of turkey is home
to the underground city of darinkuyu
built around the 8th Century BC whole
communities of up to 20 000 residents
were carved into the pliable volcanic
rock giving birth to a Labyrinth of
homes Stables Wineries and chapels all
nestled beneath the earth's surface
but now with new technologies Architects
and Engineers can drill ever deeper into
the Earth building Subterranean
megastructures that would have made your
average residents of Darren kuyu choke
on his mead as you can imagine digging
as deep as the Empire State Building is
tall presents a myriad of unique
challenges that we must overcome the
biggest of which is making sure it
doesn't collapse in on itself to ensure
our little earthscaper Sims don't get
buried alive good old reinforced
concrete famed for its sturdiness and
Longevity will be widely employed but
Engineers will also dabble in
cutting-edge reinforcement techniques
like soil nailing and deep soil mixing
which mechanically Blends the existing
soil with cement
we're also going to have to funnel
plenty of light down there to ensure a
healthy and pleasant living space
Architects will employ light Wells
mirrors and even fiber optic cables to
send sunlight Into the structure's
Depths green spaces and indoor gardens
can be added to Spruce of the Aesthetics
and boost air quality that is growing
research like Greenery is a crucial
ingredient for maintaining good mental
health Energy Efficiency will take
center stage in Earth scraper designs by
tapping into geothermal power with heat
tubes these structures will capitalize
on the Earth's consistent temperatures
for heating and cooling purposes
London Underground is an excellent
example of this technology in use some
above ground apartment buildings in
London are now being heated solely by
the residual heat collected from the
earth via underground pipes that run
through London's tube Network moreover
water that falls into the Earth scraper
can be harvested and recycled to
decrease strain on Urban utilities
speaking of water you're probably
thinking what happens if it floods after
all we're essentially putting a giant
bucket into the floor and hoping
it doesn't fill with water
fear not there will be gargantuan
Advanced Drainage Systems to quickly
evacuate excess water but it's actually
groundwater seepage that poses a more
significant threat that's water from the
surrounding soil gradually making its
way in kind of like Rising dump in your
home
for this Architects will Implement
watertight concrete systems that have
already been tried and tested for years
in your average swimming pool
we also shouldn't ignore earthquakes
meticulous Structural Engineering will
be needed to ensure they endure seismic
activity
Solutions like base isolation systems
and seismic dampers have been
effectively employed in many existing
buildings notably across Japan such as
the Tokyo Metropolitan government
building one place that's genuinely
looking to expand downwards is Mexico
City a vast Metropolis of almost 9
million people here traditional
Solutions have struggled to keep up with
the city's rapid growth especially since
the city has put strict height
restrictions on new buildings within the
historic Center so skyscrapers aren't an
option enter bunker architectura an
avant-garde architectural firm with a
revolutionary proposal a 300 meter deep
inverted pyramid-shaped Earth scraper
designed to provide it much needed
residential commercial and cultural
space in the heart of Mexico City and
when they say the heart they literally
mean it this audacious Venture aims to
Tunnel into the Earth right below the
City's renowned Central Square the
circle by only using the space beneath
the square the Earth scraper preserves
this iconic Plaza and offers a
resourceful answer to Mexico City's
spatial predicament the design envisions
a sequence of terrorist levels
plummeting deep into the Earth each
accommodating a distinct purpose such as
residential office retail museums and
various cultural amenities in fact the
suggested design spans a staggering 65
stories this would be a huge Boon to the
city's usable space without adding a
single inch to its footprint on the
surface of the Earth
however this concept is not without its
hurdles boasting an estimated price tag
of 800 million dollars the financial
feasibility remains uncertain and
understandable concerns over impacting
the historic City Center have made the
locals get a bit itchy about the project
besides Financial obstacles there are
numerous engineering and logistical
issues to overcome as mentioned earlier
earthquake resistance is a crucial
factor for Earth scrapers and Mexico is
especially vulnerable being located near
five tectonic plates Bunker's design
suggests using a flexible lightweight
carbon fiber reinforced concrete shell
yeah we've all put one of those on our
Christmas list haven't we which would
supposedly Shield it from seismic
vibrations
even with these hurdles bunker
architecturus earthscraper concept
remains an exciting and novel approach
to combating urban sprawl and I for one
think it would be pretty amazing to see
it come to fruition anyhow the idea has
already encouraged other Architects to
think outside or rather beneath the Box
take for example Japan's shimazu
corporation which has proposed an even
more daring project called the ocean
spiral a vision of a self-sustaining
underwater Metropolis
truthfully it seems unlikely that
Mexico's Earth scraper will happen in
the near future if at all
but there are a few smaller Earth
scraper-esque projects you can actually
visit today such as Montreal's
underground city also known as rezo a
sprawling Subterranean network spanning
over 20 miles
containing a plethora of commercial
spaces including shopping centers
offices hotels museums and public
transport hubs the climate-controlled
space makes it a popular destination
during the city's Frosty Winters andreso
has attracted around 500 000 daily
visitors since its Inception in 1962
proving that Earth scrapers aren't
solely for addressing urban sprawl there
can also be a major tourist attraction
although let's be honest here rezo is a
bit more shopping more than avant-garde
architecture it is still kind of Cooler
skyscraper mad New York has finally set
its eyes below ground too the low line
is an audacious Endeavor to more for
forsaken Subterranean trolley terminal
into a lively public Oasis this
pint-sized Earth scraper would be
outfitted with cutting-edge tech like
solar collectors and Fiber Optic Cables
fuddling sunlight into its depths sadly
after a decade of planning the project
now looks to be dead due to financial
issues but it isn't just bowling alleys
and boutiques that Earth scrapers could
accommodate numerous Industries like
agriculture could reap the rewards of
subterranean Solutions imagine
underground hydroponic Farms that
collect and conserve water and offer a
precisely controlled climate for
year-round cultivation data centers
could exploit Earth scrapers innate
insulation and geothermal cooling
capabilities cutting down on costs and
if we do ever get to Mars we might
utilize Earth scrapers to create
underground habitats shielding us from
harsh surface conditions and Cosmic
radiation You could argue that building
Earth scrapers here on Earth is a
priority so we have time to test them
out and perfect the technology before we
expand into the stars in 2017 a team of
MIT students won the international
competition Mars City design with their
Redwood forest proposal it envisioned an
interconnected network of Earth scrapers
on Mars with numerous Living Spaces
below ground each topped with a large
transparent Dome full of lush vegetation
so as we Ponder the particulars of the
future of urban living let's not gaze
solely skywards but consider the
potential lurking beneath our feet
because who knows by trying something
new we could reshape our cities for the
better or at the very least we can build
our own Zion before the machines take
over
thanks for watching